good morning it is good to be here this
morning and some would say it's good to
be anywhere I'm grateful to be in this
place I have certainly visited this
Chapel on many different occasions this
is the first time for me as this is a
congregation connected with the
University and it's a very different
feel but nonetheless it is good to be in
the house of thought one more time in
this house in particular that's what
they say in my tradition I'm Baptist so
I know something about being in the
house of God and having these churchy
things to say so I want to talk this
morning about something that is not a
word we often use it's a dirty word it's
a word that doesn't sit well with many
of us it certainly doesn't sit well with
people from my tradition in my history
it's the word servant it is for me a
revolutionary word as I hope to share
with you this morning
given that as an introduction let me
first pause and prayer for God's
illumination for God's Holy Spirit
breathing into this message it into our
hearts and lives let's pray we thank you
God for this day we thank you that we
have the opportunity to come here to
worship you in spirit and in truth to
sing the songs of Zion and to hear your
word a fit word an on-time word a word
that would help us in our relationship
with you our relationship with one
another and our relationship to the
world beyond these walls
breathe Oh Holy Spirit into our minds
and hearts but the words of my mouth
and the meditations of all of our hearts
be acceptable to you O Lord our strength
and our Redeemer amen so there are four
verses there were part of that gospel
scripture that I want to read by way of
repetition and they are his mother said
that is Jesus mother to the servants do
whatever he tells you
and Jesus ordered the servants and verse
7 fill the pots with water and they
filled them to the brim now fill your
pictures and take them to the hosts
jesus said and they did when the hosts
tasted the water that had become wine he
didn't know what had just happened but
the servants knew he called out to the
bridegroom most of the time these four
verses and the messages related to them
are secondary to what is the common
subject of that Cana story that wedding
a story you see it's commonplace to
concentrate on the ability of Jesus to
transform water into wine and that's
indeed a miracle in and of itself and
countless sermons have been devoted to
just that topic and I thought about this
message and I wanted to focus focus on
that initially and demonstrate it for
your own seeing you know colored water
in water transforming water and that
kind of thing some people talk about the
chemical reactions that take place and
what is actually going on in that
chemical reaction the power of
transformation and of itself but these
are not the focus of my message today
these are not times in which and things
common happen the times in which we live
or not commonplace at all we live in a
society that accepts war and struggles
to survive
we live in a society that is teetering
on the brink of economic distress and
certainly I see that a 10 percent
unemployment rate across the country and
about 9 percent in Connecticut and
located in places in which I travel with
people who are homeless families who are
struggling each and every day to make
ends meet
we live in a society that reminds us
that some things are as much as we would
like for it to be out of our control
tragedies like the horrific scene in
Haiti my eyes have been affixed on the
tragedy on the devastation that to my
mind is inexplicable
is incomprehensible is beyond anything
that I have ever experienced a hundred
thousand people fear dead you know
because you have seen those stories on
television and in the news and there is
a concert that is to take place to try
to do something to alleviate the pain
the anguish the devastation the despair
and to minister and the ways in which we
can all to make the lives of those who
are experiencing death and sadness and
sorrow a little bit better we struggle
to understand and respond in ways that
are not commonplace
to that particular tragedy through
generous generous donations heartfelt
prayers and acts of kindness therefore
on this day that we mark Martin Luther
King's birthday in this church and this
weekend across the country the message
that I thought about sharing could not
just be common
ladies it cannot simply include
utterances about his vision his values
his virtues or even his vices instead it
must focus on the uncommon place-- I
know that's not a word but you know what
I mean
it is the unnamed the unknown the
unwitting and the unsung people in the
story Cana story and who are they they
are indeed the servants then and yes for
today each of us who are gathered here
in this holy and hallowed place the
servants were there working a gig they
had a job to do there was a celebration
of mammoth and wonderful proportions who
would not want to be in a joyous place
celebrating the union of two people now
we know nothing about who those people
are they're not even mentioned they are
indeed incidental to the story
that's not the way wedding sorry you
know the bride and the groom the two
partners are really like right in the
thick of it so they should figure
prominently but it was all the things
around the story all the things around
the two couple did the couple that
seemed to be important it's an uncommon
way to think about a wedding a story
these servants as I'd imagine them were
you've seen receptions before people
with trays of food perhaps and and wine
overflowing and carrying wine back and
forth
it was indeed a happy time where two
unmentioned people were being joined
together Jesus and his mother were
invited to the wedding the scripture
says while there the most embarrassing
thing
happened the wine ran out now I don't
know if there's anyone here who has
planned a party but you know when you
don't have enough it is indeed a problem
it's a serious problem it makes people
think that you either didn't plan well
your resources weren't adequate or you
were just purely stupid and couldn't
figure out how many people you were
going to have and have a little extra
when I've planned receptions before the
caterers have said to me well if I have
a number of 120 then I'll prepare for
125 just to make sure that there was
enough to go around and perhaps some
leftover this was a distressing thing
for the host that the wine was about to
run out and it got to the dredges of
that particular wine collection if you
will and so yes of course so was to
protect the host so was to ensure that
there would not be embarrassing
something needed to be done and along
comes Jesus he was the one who could do
something about that particularly
embarrassing the situation but he didn't
really do the work for the servants did
the heavy lifting that was their
assignment it was their contribution to
the story
Jesus just to a supervising the
particular situation overseeing the
situation but the real heavy lifting is
done by the servants heavy lifting I
said not lifting barbells or weights
while they may have had some kind of
preparation who knows not bodybuilders
or people who engage in exercises that
keep them muscular well I don't need
them but maybe there's some people who
do no no no no this was not Wow this was
not only
the heavy lifting that had to do with
physical ability physical prowess this
kind of heavy lifting was much much more
than that
you see these servants did four things
that allowed me to see the kind of heavy
lifting that they were supposed to do
that they actually did first they
followed a divine direction they were
told by Mary do whatever he tells you
now some of us would have had a problem
with that kind of direction it's like a
mother talking to a child and sometimes
you want to talk back to the mother or
the father and to be able to engage in a
discourse as to exactly why it is that I
can't you can't we can't do the thing
that we are being told to do it is
common for us to have conversation with
others but there's a point at which even
that kind of conversation stops the
statement is do it because I told you
don't ask why just do it so they follow
divine direction
and secondly they filled the jars of
water now you have to imagine there were
six stone jars that were 18 to 20
gallons each which means that there was
about 200 gallons of water that had to
be put into those jars the jars were
reserved for purification for the rite
of purification in the Jewish tradition
but Jesus said fill the jar so that's
another point of discussion you want me
to do what with 200 gallons of are you
kidding no but you know what the
scripture says
Jesus told them to fill the jars and it
says they did so doesn't say that
there's any conversation or discussion
doesn't say anything about whether or
not there were individuals who left it
says the servants filled the jars and
they fill the jars and this is the third
thing they filled the jars not to the
bottom most not to the middle but they
filled it to the tippity-top they
fulfilled their mission and you know
there are those of us who say well we'll
do enough just to get by there are those
of us who say it will do enough to be
able to show that we have demonstrated
our commitment minimal though it may be
there are those of us who say we will
follow the orders that we have been
given we will complete the task yes we
will fulfill the mission drop by drop
bit by bit
little by little now I envisioned how
they could have you know a conveyor belt
or some sort of traveling you know water
hose and not that they didn't have water
hoses we don't know exactly what process
they went through but it had to be
something that took some time so the
determination with which they engaged in
this pack filling its
experience to be a little lengthy and
forth and lastly